to all of you I'm Barbara Cochran I'm
the president of the radio television
news Directors Association and we're so
pleased to be co-hosting this event with
Warner independent pictures and we're
also so very pleased that George Clooney
grant Heslov and David Strathairn could
be here with us this evening I hope that
you've had a chance to see or will have
a chance to see good night and good luck
anyone who cares about history and the
future of journalism will want to see
this film we're delighted to be
co-hosting as I said with Warner
independent pictures and I'd also like
to introduce two of our leaders our
board leaders who are here with us
tonight
they are Dan Shelley who is our rtm da
board chairman and news director of WTMJ
a.m. in Milwaukee and also Bob pretty
who is chairman of our educational
foundation and news director of Missouri
net in Jefferson City Missouri and Bob
is also our historian and is really the
connection to how we got involved with
this movie if you've had a chance to
attend one of the screenings of good
night and good luck you can understand
why the radio television news Directors
Association took a special interest in
this film the film begins and ends with
a famous and often quoted speech made by
Murrow at the 1958 Artie MDA convention
and today nearly half a century later
Artie NDA still fights for the same
freedoms and upholds the same standards
that Murrow stood for we represent more
than 3000 news executives and staff
working in radio television and other
electronic media at Network and local
levels in the United States and 30
countries around the world and many of
you who are here tonight are RT NDA
members and we're really glad to see you
here Artie NDA's ties to Murrow go back
a long way and continue to this day
Murrow was one of the earliest
recipients of Artie NDA's high as
the Paul Wight award which is named for
the first news director of CBS News RT
NDA led the fight to get morels likeness
on a US postage stamp and our annual
award for excellence in news coverage is
called the Edward R Murrow award
I even have murrow's application for RT
and EEA membership framed in our office
and for those of you who are RT NDA
members you should know that he paid $10
in dues a little more than that now so
perhaps it's not surprising the seeing
good night and good luck made me wonder
what Merle woods think about what's
going on today what would he say about a
reporter for the New York Times who
today marks her 76th day in jail for
refusing to disclose the source of the
story she never even wrote or what would
he say about a Providence Rhode Island
television reporter who endured for
months under house arrest
also for refusing to name a confidential
source would Merle be surprised that
this many years later television radio
coverage is still barred from the
highest court in the land would he be
alarmed by the curtain of secrecy that
shuts off more and more information from
the public and on a positive note would
he recognize his worthy successors in
the countless television and radio
journalists who brought the true story
of Hurricane Katrina to the American
people and finally galvanized government
at all levels into action
I know our speakers tonight may get into
some of these issues and now it's time
to hear from them and to moderate the
discussion I'm delighted to introduce
someone who knew Edward Murrow well
enough to call him Edie and who was in
fact the last correspondent hired by
Murrow at CBS News
Marvin calvess was a correspondent at
CBS and NBC for 30 years serving his
Moscow bureau chief chief diplomatic
correspondent and host of Meet the Press
which was where I got to know Marvin as
his executive producer so it's nice to
be reunited with him tonight
in 1987 Marvin returned to Harvard his
alma mater to found the Joan Shorenstein
Center on the Pres politics and public
policy since 1999 he has been a senior
fellow at the Shorenstein Center and he
continues to write books and to lead
discussions such as tonight's on the
role of media in our democracy ladies
and gentlemen please welcome
Marvin calve and our speakers thank you
thank you very much
thank you Thank You Barbara very much
and I never called him that I called him
sir I don't know a single television
reporter in this country whom the name
Edward Amuro
is not a legend beyond reach and yet
Murrow for those of us who worked with
him was very human very vulnerable
incredibly decent and a superb unafraid
reporter when he hired me in June 1957
he took two tall glasses out of the desk
drawer and a bottle of Johnnie Walker
Black Label and he started pouring it
was ten o'clock in the morning and I
must have had a look of absolute horror
on my face Murrow looked up and he said
oh dear you don't drink no I replied
does that mean there's no job no he said
but it does make it more difficult quite
a guy let me quickly introduce our panel
and get right into our discussion on my
right is the director co-writer and one
of the stars of the movie good night and
good luck George Clooney one of my
family's favorite actors he was a
journalism student in college his dad
was an anchorman for 25 years so
journalism is very much include his
blood in the movie Clooney plays the
role of Fred friendly who was murrow's
producer and right arm on my left
David Strathearn a very accomplished
actor who plays Murrow and whose cadence
in speaking murrow's lines is so
remarkably true to life that at one
point in my second viewing of the movie
this week I closed my eyes and just
listened and it was Edie I mean it's a
remarkable of performance and you've
already won I think one award in Europe
for your acting in this movie and I'm
quite sure other rewards will follow
and finally to my immediate right is
grant Heslov who is the producer and
with Clooney the co-writer of the movie
he's the president of a movie production
company he's been a director and an
actor in the movies and on television
and he's currently directing a tenth
part HBO series based on the Ten
Commandments okay my first question is
to George Clooney tell us George briefly
about the movie and why you did it
briefly briefly well my father's an
anchorman we you know we've had some of
this conversation with some of you
already my father I grew up in
Cincinnati Ohio or across the river in
Kentucky and a big part of my growing up
was you know when you're a local
anchorman you're not making a lot of
money really and my mom was working at
the TV station as well so from the time
I was about six years old our babysitter
was WKRC in Cincinnati and they would
just drop us off and my dad would go to
do a radio show at WC KY for a couple
hours and my mom would be working on the
show the Bob Jones show or one of the
shows that was going on there and I sort
of would just we hang out at honest at
this TV station and I slowly I became a
cue card boy at eight years old I was
operating cue cards I was a floor
director when I was nine years old I was
I was operating the teleprompter for my
dad's news at eleven years old which is
a funny thing that you'll remember this
but teleprompters at that time were you
took you know it was a I be M Selectric
typewriter with a giant font and you
would did all of that the stories were
written out and huge pages and then they
would tape them into end and you would
file them through with this camera over
the top they would run and at the
commercial breaks my dad would go cut
that Thursday's child piece you'd
literally cut a piece of paper out and
tape it up and file it through like yeah
you know so it was a big part of my life
and what I remember most about it and
what I was most proud of my father about
was
sitting on that floor watching him with
good reporters like Debra Dixon and
Howard Ain who were reporters in
Cincinnati at the time watching them
each pitch their news story and say this
is a lead story and watching how a news
broadcast at night was made watching him
fight as on a local level to do national
news which isn't always easy on open in
local broadcasting watching the fights
that he would have constantly with
general managers of course as as you
know always exist watching some of the
most beautiful bravest general managers
a guy named Bob Wiegand stand up and
fight for my dad's news program when it
costs went a fraud cast and fired him
for doing it
and it was a brave move because he knew
he was going to get fired for it
watching the constant battle of this is
1969 or 1970 watching the constant
battle of entertainment pushing news off
the air watching those fights and I
Murrow growing up in our household
Murrow and Cronkite were the two great
heroes because they were the two men
that you could point to two very
specific moments in history that were
that changed an American policy based on
it Murrow going at McCarthy when people
suddenly realized they weren't alone in
their fear or there or the dislike of
the policy and when Cronkite went to
Vietnam and he came back and said this
is a best-of stalemate and Johnson
decides not to run for president because
of that that you could point to great
sort of moments and they were pinnacle
moments on our family that were talked
about the box of lights and wires speech
that was done here my dad used to recite
to us as little kids so I started
revisiting about three years ago when I
started to see things that worried me
not about news although certainly there
were issues about news but there were
also governmental issues were worries of
using fear to start to erode away at
civil liberties
and worries of not censorship but people
sort of self censoring themselves
because if you'd lose access if you ask
a tough question in a in a in the
newsroom or in a in a presidential press
conference if you have to ask a tough
question you get sent to the back of the
room and you lose access and the dangers
of trying to balance those things and I
thought it was an interesting time to
talk about these again not not to I'm
not a soapbox kind of guy I don't
believe in standing up and saying this
is right and this is wrong it's so much
more complex than that we make Paley a
very complex character we don't make him
a bad guy we put them in a tough
situation I think I think all of these
issues aren't black and white but much
more gray and I miss some of the black
and white issues and that's why we did
it
David let me ask you you say you're
quoted as saying you wanted to show what
was going on in murrow's head as you
were exploring the role itself what did
you find what I'd if I did that it
what sort of person ah vast vast saying
those words over and over was not only a
mazing privilege but it was an education
but it was an insight to a kind of will
and integrity that I know exists and
pieces of him even in this room but
there was something I tried to give a
sense that in behind this seemingly
language posed at sometimes catatonic or
relaxed guy who was sitting in the back
of the room that you could think well
he's just having a nice day there with
his cigarette that behind that there
there we these distr
bow jet of of intellect and analysis and
editing and distilling and questioning
going on until large extent the camera
does that robber tells what's camera
catches those moments of like of many of
us candidly but I came to feel that in
this man who you've known and many of
you have met that there was something
very simple that was spawned in polecat
North Carolina and and kept growing
growing growing all the way through the
lumber yard fields in Northwest through
the through the tutelage of idilu'
Anderson to the society tables of London
and and I think it popped out publicly
or up came and started pounding in his
brain when he went to Birkenau and
returning with returning with a deep
sense of the common man and the voice
that is crying out there and that's what
I think he he was committed to and you
know marrow is the kind of reporter who
in world war ii during the London Blitz
went out to cover the Blitz in what way
he took a microphone and put it very
very close to the ground as people were
entering right to hear the for just to
hear the footsteps walking past how he
would speak over that to give some sense
to people of what was actually going on
yeah right you were as producer of this
you're doing a black and white movie
yeah whoops which is which is quite
remarkable today and you were using the
actual words of Senator McCarthy so he
becomes a character in the movie he's a
great he's a great actor of the film
you want to take out an ad for your
consideration for Best Supporting Actor
you think it would be one of those great
ads time angry he was riveting how did
you work that out that was out
interesting the the black and white
George had always wanted to do the film
in black and white there was never
really any discussion about it it was we
wanted to put people right in in in the
period what and when we talked about who
was going to play McCarthy we every time
we talked about it we felt that whoever
we got to play the role the audience
would think that he was to arch and that
he was over playing it and at some point
George just said you know what let's
just let's just use the footage we've
been looking at the footage for years I
mean as we researched and technically
the footage at that time was was what 40
years old yeah
plus or 50 more than that well we went
to CES and we just started looking
through the archives and it the the the
kinescopes
it was a know everything was in all
every format every so it was a mess so
that took some time and then once we
actually got it it was a question of
just you know of restoring some of the
footage to try to make it match our
existing footage and make it match the
story yeah that then put it in so that
indeed he was a character almost
answering direct questions but also it
in a way what we decided was murrow's
broadcast which the genius of murrells
broadcast was but when he went directly
at McCarthy was he use his own words
because he can't rebut yourself and that
was brilliant really because he said
what are you going to say I didn't say
that and fight with yourself so we
thought the best thing to do in a in a
time where there is some revisionist
history about how maybe McCarthy was
right that are going around right now we
thought it was important to do that
again and treat it like a journalist
would like my father would he said get
the facts right double source everything
and we did and so we thought the best
source of
McCarthy was McCarthy no question you
found the right source on that but let
me ask you a question about that because
it's it interested me given the
arguments in contemporary journalism
today in other words what is the proper
role of a journalist in our society if
you go back to what ed was doing at that
time he was he was very engaged in his
story he was not a detached observer
he was editorializing sure and he was
editorializing straight away so that if
an observer a friendly observer say of
Fox News today will look at what it is
that you have done to the McCarthy
character could that person not feel
wait a minute this this guy was
railroaded by a liberal media run amuck
crazy well that there's no question
about it you could and you could make
the argument that he opened the door for
editorializing because television at
that point had been rather timid you
know the owl stops her block Jack Gould
had all gone at him in the papers at
garnet McCarthy but no one had really
faced it in television at that point you
could make a lot of those arguments I
would argue that the same argument that
Murrow made which was that the other
side has been represented rather well
because he did have sort of a bully
pulpit and was able to get on the air
whenever he wanted to and you know
Murrow was late to the game he wasn't
you know he had a lot of good friends in
New York going when the hell are you
going to get in so it was a it is look
you're right again it's not black and
white there are very difficult issues to
talk about when you talk about the idea
of editorializing because it opens the
door for some tremendously biased
reporting well what David go ahead sir
but he said and it started with Milo
Radulovich
program that the
these are the words of Fred friendly and
myself this is not endorsed or supported
or sanctioned by Alcoa or even the
student so he had he said from whence
this comes and I think what's happening
today you don't know from where it comes
whose agenda it is and also remember
that it wasn't as you you know that it
wasn't a news broadcast it was a
magazine show for that matter wasn't you
know they weren't doing the and tonight
these are the things that happened it
was a once a week news show so there was
some room for editorializing although I
I you as you were saying there wasn't
really any of that that was going on not
before the time it was it was very
proper and correct and Murrow was
breaking the mold when he did this and
in your character bill Paley who was not
here among us but bill Paley was a
justifiably concerned when he watched
his number one star breaking the mold
right and what is going to come of this
and what came of it was that
Alcoa pulled out and that it reached a
certain point where Paley had to turn
tomorrow and say you're out as a Sunday
I mean as a weekly program on Tuesday
night you're going to give me five hours
on Sunday and afternoon was regarded as
the ghetto in television in in many ways
the the showdown between Murrow and
McCarthy destroyed both of them in many
ways in many ways the fight was very
similar you know they didn't kick
McCarthy out of the Senate they censured
him and stuck him in the back let him
sit back there and not talk not long
after this Murrow was sort of sent off
to to do much less at CBS until he
really quit until he just wasn't going
to take it anymore so there were there's
some similarities and there and how it
ended so it isn't as if in this great
battle between the two giants Murrow
representing journalism and McCarthy
representing an extreme form of American
politics that there was any winner
I think that well that may be true I
think I always find that there's a
winner because who was the winner well I
would say journalism ultimately in a way
I find that it is but German or just
minute journalism how could you say was
the winner because in the speech in
Chicago right
what Murrow was describing is an
industry in despair but again I always
go back to this which is you know it's
the Jefferson idea of given a free press
or a free government I'll take a free
press he got to get up and say that and
you know it wasn't very well received
when he got up at the to give the speech
it was sort of you know they were kind
of there to give him a gold watch and he
sort of it wasn't it wasn't the nicest
time for everybody pissed off Bailey
forever at that point that was there any
Franklin and Frank Stanton from that
point on he was mad at Stanton because
Stanton had told people that person the
person was rehearsed and he was he was a
little angry at that along the way at
least from everything everyone told us
but I still I go back to the idea that
it is about the diligence of reporting
you know I'm thrilled to be here because
because I have such respect for
reporting because I find that ultimately
it is what writes history it is what
shapes opinion it is everything and he
believed it and it always loses its mind
every 30 or 40 years we go a little
crazy as a country we go a little crazy
every third you know we get bombed and
Pearl Harbor and then we grab all the
japanese-americans and throw them in
detention camps because we're scared we
come to our senses and we fix it and
what fixes it always what leads the
charge from from burning witches at the
stake to the civil rights movement to
women voting to Vietnam what leads the
way always has been the freedom of press
and people in this room journalists
always and that has been the check and
balance that is what is so important
about the Fourth Estate period you will
get no strong argument
how is the implication of what you've
just said that you have an a strong and
perhaps even growing unease with the
developments that you see before you
today and that there was some
relationship between your desire to do
the Moreau McCarthy program and what it
is that you may be observing today with
a smile on your face well I will say
this um there meant you're my father as
an anchorman used to always say to me he
went at Carter because of their I think
he was arguing about the OPEC nations
raising the price of gas or there was
some issue like that he went at Gerald
Ford for pardoning Nixon you know it was
the idea was not partisan the idea was
as a journalist he felt that his job was
to constantly diligently challenged
Authority because the one thing we've
learned over the history of time is that
Authority or government unchecked and
unchallenged always corrupts without
exception always and to him it was his
sworn duty even if it was someone he
liked which happened to be a lot I find
that there was and there's every once in
a while I found that there were some
lapses I think you know the New York
Times wrote a piece apologizing about
not really questioning enough about the
weapons of mass destruction I think it's
interesting that most of those were
truth pillars particles uh and she's in
jail you know she should never go to
jail for not revealing her sources but
maybe for a couple of those stories
relationship with Ahmed Chalabi but I
don't want you into that but it is a
it's like you said it is a you know for
me I found that there were dangerous you
know it's tough again I'll say this I
came out as publicly I didn't know press
conference maybe like get interviewed
and they'd say what do you think about
this and I'd say I think we should ask a
few more questions before we send out
50,000 kids and they get shot at and I
always put on the front of a magazine
and called the trader and I'm a big kid
I could take that they're not burning me
at the stake and they're not bringing me
in front of a house on you know on
American Activities Committee so we're
evolving along the way now they're just
a couple of people that are sort of
unkind to me I can take that I'm a big
kid
I deserve it if I'm going to speak up
but I found that we had a period of time
where we lacked we and I say we as in
the son of a journalist and this I
always found myself as it was a big part
of my life we lacked some of the nerve
to ask some of the questions that were
most important to ask at a time that
were the most important time to ask it
some of it happens great journalism goes
on non-stop but you can find it anytime
you want to and go look for it we're
fractured now harder you know you go to
the you go to the network that best
represents your political view now
rather than sort of starting with the
same facts it's okay that's fair enough
- I just found that there was a
dangerous trend of not asking tough
questions hard to ask them because you
hate this trend now by contemporary
journalists asking questions of
authority I think not as much now I find
that nowadays it's been with a little
bit of distance and the ability to not
be characterized as unpatriotic you know
I did tons of the sites that called me
you know why do you I went to a party at
my friend Jerry Weintraub's house who's
you know filled with that you know
Republicans a lot of whom were my
friends and a guy was like why do you
hate America and I'm like you know it's
my country right or wrong and I thought
well my country right or wrong and
blacks are sitting in the back of the
bus and women aren't voting and we're
still in Vietnam my country right or
wrong
the theory of our country is to
constantly diligently question authority
that's what we that's why we left King
George is not just your right it's your
duty and so that's to me why this was to
me the most important world was
journalism and you chose to use the
Merle McCarthy confrontation as the
vehicle through which you would express
or try to express this underlying good
well I will say this you guys have read
or know the speeches as well as anybody
um when you hear those speeches you
cannot help but feel patriotic he is the
most you know he is a patriot of any is
a brilliant writer and why he is so
brilliant is because he was always on
constitutional issues all the people who
want to rewrite history and say that
McCarthy was right about the Communists
and Murrow was wrong
missed the point Murrow never once
defended any of those people as not
being communists he always said you will
note that the senator nor this reporter
know whether or not Annie Lee Moss is or
is not a communist we demand that she
has the right to face her accuser it is
our constitutional right it's our writ
of habeas corpus right do you feel that
you were part and party to the the
civics lesson that we have just gotten
from George Clooney sorry well I've
known Georgian and his father for so
long that I've I've been indoctrinated
for you he drank the potion okay no I
you know I don't I
it's interesting you know when you're
writing this stuff let we had
discussions when we would be working on
speeches or we would read a speech and
we would you know there was no way you
couldn't make a parallel for today but
we certainly didn't set out that wasn't
the purpose of the piece it really was
to explore the the idea of entertainment
you know the news versus entertainment
and how that how that plays out and
everything everything else was gray
Vienna and it you know but you could
have chosen a thousand of us
subjects aside from MacArthur to do that
we could have yes we could I mean I
would have been too easy yeah without
that would have been wrong that was
wrong wrong you know yeah nevermind
David do you feel did you feel that you
were part of a a kind of crusade when
you were doing this movie not really no
no sure that the air was thick with it
but you know any any attempt to make
your art or make art or make a artistic
statement is going to tread upon things
that everybody in some part of their
life will experience and it's always a
crusade I hate that word except it it is
that you do you make a blind charge with
your vision up here and your hope back
here and hopefully a bunch of friends
with you to to achieve that blend of or
that dovetailing of an artistic
entertainment or something compelling
enough to capture our imaginations and
along with that you educate you
illuminate you even inspire and that's
what we felt like every day was we were
learning something we were inspired by
Murrow and George and grants vision and
we had a lot of hope that at least we
would succeed in making it something
that people would entertain as an idea
and and as an artistic thing sure it
felt like a crusade but most the time it
just felt like lung cancer was an
amazing thing everyone was smoking
everyone that's read he didn't smoke
thank God I can't smoke yeah that's
the only reason George didn't do it with
Armour is because he didn't want to
smoke it's true you know you know how on
if you if you get on a sound stage if
you guys are ever on a sound stage you
know you can't smoke at all and usually
the lunch break will be a crowd about
eight guys standing outside smoking this
was the only set you've ever seen where
there'd be 30 people standing outside
like you go let's go back in it look
like Gary Indiana I granted it hasn't in
the back of your mind that when you were
doing this movie good night and good
luck which everybody knows is the way in
which Merle would end his commentaries
that you were you were trying to send a
message perhaps to the White House to
the president no you know when we wrote
this we didn't know who the president
got his line drugged on we didn't know
who the president was going to be when
we wrote this you wrote this last year
wrote it 15 minutes ago we were writing
it last year in the middle of the we
were finishing it last year in the
middle of the election sure we were
fairly sure who it's gonna be
so that's cuz I'm such an go tell me so
did you have George Bush in mind when
you were thinking of the heart and soul
of this movie well yeah I mean the other
thought of the thought had crossed our
mind we'd had discussions about that but
it's certainly as I said the bigger
discussions were really about the state
of of news you know what is the state of
news in your judgment I think it's a
good healthy Enterprise at this time
what's your what do you think no no no I
ask the questions
you know I go though a matching arrival
to go to a master I think yeah man who
did it
who's done it right though we'll we'll
switch it around I think the state I
think I think that we the viewing
probably get the news that we deserve
that's an interesting idea we get the
news that we asked for picking up
George's point that people turn to
networks that have the point of view
that they that they like yeah if a bunch
of over talked about that once we said
it's so fractured that you'll go used to
be you started with three networks and
basically you got the same information
right and you took it home and you had
your own social and political views and
you sort of digested and you came right
with your honor right and now you go to
the place that basically reinforces your
belief system so the fact base are very
different you know if you call my my my
aunt and uncle right now they would
swear to you that Saddam Hussein was
attached to 9/11 was attached to a kite
and those are facts I don't think
they're facts myself but that's because
I you know I watched other things or
read other things I think people don't
read as much I think that's a little
dangerous not to be knocking broadcast
news but I think it's also good to read
a little bit along the way I think that
I but I think the news is out there for
you to get you can still find it that's
the beauty of it it is lovely absolutely
but it takes work it takes a little more
work and that's that may be good too may
be bad you know I think there's going to
be a point and you're in our history it
is cyclical where we're going to turn
around and go I really want to know some
real information it's important right
now you find when serious things happen
people go back to the things that they
trust the most let me I can't resist
then this kind of a movie which would
which certainly is going to stimulate
people those who watch it will be
stimulated to think important thoughts
yes but then you get to a kind of
bottom-line question how many people at
the end of the day do you think are
going to watch this and how many people
at the end of the day will be watching
Ocean's Twelve for example well Ocean's
Twelve is a bad example right how about
a
it's 11 sleep Batman and Robin out
completely um you know what I'm good no
no but of course but you know let's say
this one episode of a failed WB network
show will get more people watching it
than most major films you know the truth
is television obviously hasn't it's not
even comparable the kind of power you
know the television has so a film like
this it's not designed to be a huge hit
what it's designed to do is to be a
debate for some people to inspire a
couple of people if they want to be
inspired to listen if if out of this
movie some kid in a Columbia University
where you know fred was so proud to be a
part of if some kid watches this film
and says you know what I'd like that and
I like those set of standards and does
it and gets involved we win you
absolutely do no question about that
we've got about 10 more minutes and for
those of you who'd like to ask a
question I am wide open to do so right
here please identify yourself is there a
microphone around that we there I'll
yell it out if you'd like well go ahead
okay as a former broadcaster I should
have a voice my name is Francis Hardin
I'm a graduate of the Graduate School of
Journalism at Columbia fred was one of
my professors first let me say I thought
the film was wonderful I thought your oh
you got asked a question I want to ask
you about your portrayal of Fred all of
us who know Fred know that he was a big
guy big hands big feet baby boy your
idea yeah he wasn't a looker
that's right baby
what I didn't want to ask you about how
you decided to portray Fred and why well
there was it it was a you know believe
it or another was an economic decision
was a seven and a half million dollar
black-and-white film starring David
Strathairn no one would give us the
money okay so I had I had the play no no
oh listen the the sit the simple point
is black and white alone is impossible
to finance so so for me being in it was
one way to get it financed and to do it
for for a buck but that but I also found
that I didn't want to do Fred because
Fred takes over a room I met him when I
constitute a little version of the
Constitution in 1982 when I was a kid I
had I shall have it he took over a room
and to me what was really important in
this film were the words and these words
and what was important was not to lose
focus so I thought the camaraderie
between between a Fred and Edie was
important and I thought we did that very
well but I didn't want Fred to be what
he actually was which was the scene
stealer anyway very much so yeah he was
very much and I thought that that would
just be a disservice to the film when I
wanted to play a Jew
one thing I've never done that I've
never done that and I thought it was a
stretch when we were doing the before we
started I got a call from David friendly
who's Fred Sundberg and we were talking
he was thrilled that we were doing the
film and all that it and he said so is
George really playing my my father and I
said yes and he it was a long silence he
said have you guys ever seen my father
that's one on you it was really happy
grant was playing well he was like grad
oh yeah I know yeah this big fan of mine
okay
Luther yes please yes I'm coming on and
welcome to [ __ ] we're been covering the
White House in 68 and this is a very
managed White House it really is it just
thirty people get cold on the top
Network really rich people get to cover
the prison follow the prison overtime do
you see any way around and we are
getting tougher but okay first thing is
you to the back that seems to be the
right way isn't it doesn't know how you
handle it tough question you to the back
I don't I don't know the I mean listen
you've got a man here who you should you
could ask that question of I'm not the
man to ask that question I an observer
of the fights that my father fought and
I found that in many ways he lost those
fights over periods of time
I just always considered diligence I
consider I think that I think that the
reporter saw a weak spot in Hurricane
Katrina and found a way to get in I
think it's too bad that that weak spot
wasn't sort of picked on when it wasn't
so easy that's the thing that was so
stunning to me about Murrow was he did
it when it wasn't easy he stuck his neck
out when although all of those people
that he was working with were risking
their jobs and their careers Murrow had
a much more it a much bigger
understanding
the idea that if he shot too high and
missed he was going to saddle the
country with McCarthy for another five
years
he knew that and he understood that and
for all of his writings you underst
you get that so to me the people who
were in this room who were there the
people who were writing at the time that
it was a it was one of the bravest
things I've ever seen done and brave on
Paley's part brave on everyone's part
this Cleese journalism school and I was
speaking mr. strengthened earlier and
what's the league about you mentioned
the Johnnie Walker and my understanding
that mr. Murrow being a student of you
know how to spend it a little bit about
him was that he kept a bottle of scotch
at his feet so that when he was doing
see it now he would take a dip before
the broadcast and that was not great
I've never seen I never saw that no I
never saw that oh I never saw that but
Murrow was always extremely anxious when
he broadcast by the way and he perspired
terribly and very often in the midst
even of a radio program in other words
where was unimportant how he looked
he had a towel right there and he would
wipe himself periodically because I
never understood that because he had
done so many broadcasts he was so
totally in command of all of his
material and yet he perspired terribly
the minute he had to do something on air
the minute he was communicating
information he suddenly realized whoops
this is a very large responsibility but
you know why it is that he perspired so
much god alone those I don't know there
was somebody in the back yes please
George I'm curious fate no no hang on a
sec it's this lady right here
yes Oh also Palestinian and I'm a
journalist here an Arab American you got
Arab journalists here and I was
wondering because a lot of the stuff
that was happening there with communists
it almost same thing almost
happen or Muslim or Arab and it seems to
be that you know when you were talking
about when in the movie they talked
about communists and they were looking
at them they were like make sure you're
not a communist you have no connection
to communist before you can say what you
can say and it seems to me like that's
almost the same that's happening to a
lot of Muslims and Arabs make sure you
have no connection before you can say it
the fact that you are or not rather than
your constitutional right and my
question is in the movie and in a lot of
the discussions the Sikh you know you
seem to mention to Judith Miller and
American you know white American
journalists and their rights but also I
was wondering if you think about the
idea of people who are not necessarily
white Americans who are getting their
rights threatened but rather people will
okay but there's a couple of things you
throw through in there and and look if
the argument is obviously Jose Padilla
in Guantanamo Bay that's the best
argument could make and and that sort of
goes back to what Murrow talks about
when he talks about you cannot defend
freedom abroad by deserting it at home
the question is and and and again it's
not black and white it's always
complicated because he would say that
you have to find a balance between
protecting the state and the end of it
and the rights of the individual so you
go okay well there's Jose Padilla we go
to the Supreme Court with it and the
truth is he might be a terrorist we
don't know but either he's a criminal
and he gets the writ of habeas corpus
and he gets the right to a speedy trial
and a lawyer or he is a prisoner of war
and he gets Geneva Convention rights if
you get neither of those then you are
chipping away at the foundation of what
it is the design democracy so you're
right there are certainly parallels to
all of those sort of arguments about it
not being about white America there are
just but the problems are of course so
what do you do set them free
and so there aren't easy black and white
issues they in my mind are because I'm a
old-time constitutionalist that believes
in going strict constitutional not
strict in the supreme court strict
constitutionalist
kind of way but uh but I do believe in
the it's something just bad happen I do
believe in that over anything else I do
believe that that's the most important
issue but it's a good question I mean
you're right it's going to continue to
it's not going to get better
we are plumb out of time and I'm sorry
that other people I know wanted ask
questions but we will receive a final
benediction now from the president of
the RTN da right over Cochran and boos
Johnny Walker Black Label I don't know
about that
nobody any good this is experience to
distance
another
thank you it is a great joy to be here
with you guys and and what a lot